wow so i just remember i could still
remember till this day crying and
the rain mixing it with the tears
because that's why
this rain is salty i'm crying
so i just but i learned how to ride the
bike that day i learned after that day
i could ride the bike wow but he would
not let me go inside the house
until i could ride the bike so parents
at home if you're listening
twice here if you're teaching your kid
how to ride a bike and they can't
wait for a giant rainstorm yeah and
that's in five
four three two one hello everybody
welcome to another corona free episode
on a free
we don't know that though of the gym
i'll find out two weeks from now nick's
dead i got it every time i
i think somebody has corona i always
think it's you first thanks man
so does everyone in my family and tiff
tiff hates you dude you know why it's
because you
do not stay safe at home is that the
phrase yeah i do i stay
i stay home all the time i'm probably
when i'm not training i'm the most safe
person around bro
i get tested at least once a week
minimum
minimum yeah you know how much that
[ __ ] test cost was a hot like 125
plus 150 bucks you got a bunch of rapid
tests on i got
so much i wasted so much money i'm
immune i actually can't get it
it's impossible that's what you found
out i do the frame for the frag i do the
free ones
the free ones how long does it take uh
for you to get it usually
right around the 24 hour mark oh really
it's actually pretty fast pretty good
they say 48 but it's usually 24. but
right now they're crazy the lines and
[ __ ] are
nuts because the holiday song because
one night yeah and i think just because
it's cracking off right now too
because uh when i went to dodger stadium
it took me 30 minutes
and then sarah went to get the went to
go get tested and it took her like three
hours she had a breakdown and she called
me crying was like i'm gonna run out of
gas my battery's gonna die i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on
she's this crazy girl i'm blind crying
dude i started laughing so
but it but it but of course
we went one time and we were in line for
about like an hour
maybe an hour and a half not three hours
that's a [ __ ] long time
and i would be scared too loki because
like my car obviously
is the perfect is made out of chopsticks
but continue
um but what i was saying was like you
can tiff had to go use the restroom
flintstones
pedal foot powered i'm just like no so
tiff had to use a restroom and they and
she got out and they have porta potties
there
but it's like first staff only and but
it's like
these lines are gonna be around an hour
usually right i can't do that that's why
i just rapid test that [ __ ] yeah the
times we
like we only had to wait an hour once
most of the time it's not
when we go but she had to go pee and
they got so mad at her
yeah for peeing in the porta potty they
like they were making such a fuss about
that to clean everything out they like
spray it down which i get you know
but at the same time it's like have some
people trip a little too hard though
yeah it's like some people like oh yeah
some guy yelled at me i was at phil
yeah what happened to phil so i was at
phil's and i was doing work and i was
eating and
they have outdoor dining or whatever
right i'm sitting down i'm on my
computer eating
this sandwich and i'm having a coffee
this guy walks in this big tall lanky
white boy he was probably like
25 maybe he was a real curly headed [ __ ]
i'll say that
he walks in and he like goes curly he he
like glances at me from outside and i
just like i just like kind of made eye
contact with him i didn't think anything
of it
and i'm on my computer he's walking by
and he goes
you should put on a [ __ ] mask oh is
he trying to get his ass beat
bro and i'm on my computer and it took
me a second to be like
oh he's talking to me i'm like i'll turn
around
and i say something very generic but
like real tough guy yeah would you say
because it i i didn't realize i was like
oh [ __ ] i was like kind of mass
i was like 95
there's a lot of different ones carbon
filter no one cared who i was until i
put it on i said
a batman mask everything about your
mouth
oh that'd be awesome dude but yeah so he
walks
he's walking away as he says that and i
go
why did you go over here and say it to
my [ __ ] face and i say that you said
that yeah that's what i said that was
good
that's the classic correct saying to my
[ __ ] face dude it's like a cough in
your mouth
yeah and he's already dead like he's
already like he only ran he was already
like down the hallway
he walked pretty fast and i also didn't
realize it quick enough and he goes
i already did and he left i already did
dude and i was like this
and at first i was like i was like
really i was fantasizing about beating
this kid's ass
all day right absolutely but at the same
time it's like i really did want to be
like hey man
what's going through your [ __ ] head
bro yeah did you have someone that just
recently got coronavirus or did you just
think that like
oh or or if i was a big 200 pound white
dude
that's buff of [ __ ] would you say the
same thing to me of course you know what
it is too like
well that's why he did a drive-by
[ __ ] chastising i've never seen
somebody do that i really just was like
so i've never heard somebody
to the response to say to my face was
already d
as you said his why would i do it again
so you know like i already did it so you
know where the back door feels is right
yeah i was standing like i was sitting
right next to that door okay
at that back entrance and he was already
by like sun life like
wrapped around kind of like by lemonade
by the time he responded he was saying
that so yeah he echoed the message
yeah because you got to echo it now
that's why you couldn't tell who said it
to you you're like are you talking to me
he walks right down he's like and i was
like
what the hell i was like oh [ __ ] and i
was like well [ __ ] you man
i don't think i don't think i would have
even registered it was to me i would
have just been coughing
and just riding away
yeah i was coughing a bunch though yeah
i wasn't i was literally just sitting
there and loser but he's losing his
humanity too it's like what does that do
some people that's what i'm saying and
also i'm allowed to do this some people
are
trip to there's the anti-masters where
like everything's a hoax and whatever
that's this extreme but there's also the
super paranoid [ __ ] [ __ ] that are
like
dude mind your [ __ ] just stay away
your ass at home bro do you got to get
phil's coffee
make coffee at your own [ __ ] house
that's scary if you're that paranoid to
begin with or also just hey stay six
feet away from this dude and you're fine
yeah yeah and also just walk fast walk
around me bro like [ __ ] dude
i know there's just there's just certain
people that are like that when i was in
uh l.a years ago this is when i my
temper was really short
so this guy went
but i feel like we're close yeah
someone is gonna bro someone's gonna say
something to david where he just like
sees red
and then i'm gonna have to like pull
this guy off like dave it off no i
believe it
i'm too old for that now i don't know
last podcast all about you beating the
[ __ ]
i still feel bad about that yeah i know
and you should because you [ __ ]
almost murdered a guy but continue the
story about the time
your dick was hard the whole time it
felt it felt right
it felt so what do you call it when you
get angry you have an erection
after you hurt somebody mr tyson that's
called a murder boner
what's it no there in the [ __ ] joe
last night no seriously joe
what do you call it like i'm asking you
i'm still i'm not joking
i don't know
no what do you call it when you hit he
has that raspy voice now which i really
enjoy
do you know what's funny is i heard him
on a podcast recently talking about the
length of his table now
he was i think he was talking to willy d
or something from the ghetto boys but he
was like i made the table longer because
of that mike tyson podcast
he was like because he was so intense he
was like i was [ __ ] nervous dude like
i was nervous
and then he looks over at the jamie or
whatever and jamie was like i was
nervous too
he's like they're all scared with tyson
in the room because nobody could catch
when he was making a joke or not yeah
that was the hard part so when joe would
laugh
tyson would be like what's so funny yeah
i don't get what why are you laughing
and i feel like he was breathing was
just like he would like they would do
this he sounded like he borrowed
yeah like holy this [ __ ] polar bear
right here i feel like the last time he
was on that before the fight was
scheduled he wasn't like that
no he was a lot more chill he's a lot
more like relaxed right so you could
tell he's definitely in the warrior
mindset
you know his favorite phrase is you know
what you know what
that's what he always says now you know
what i just i want to kill somebody
but i can't yeah and it kills me on the
inside because i feel like a little
[ __ ]
that's good but seriously i lost a lot
of tyson that's good yeah that's
actually really good thank you man i
thought bart's was good and yours is
better well i think when everybody
imitates tyson they go too ham on it
they go high
they go that way his voice is in a lower
register and he's a lot more common zen
than you think that he is what other
accents can you do
huh i don't know the typical racist
asian accent that was good that was good
too
yeah but uh what what the [ __ ] you were
talking about a story about how you got
really mad at somebody oh yeah so
long story short with this one and i
think i told on the podcast but i know
exactly what that situation is because i
was outside of a chipotle
in larchmont and i was having a meeting
on the phone it was actually a radio
interview and i'm like
a good distance away from everybody else
who's eating their chipotle and i'm
there with my buddy paul kim
and so i'm sitting there and we're
laughing joking around on the radio
interview and i come and sit down
and this guy walks over to me as i'm
still on the
on having the radio interview he goes
hey you're being really [ __ ] annoying
by the way
and i'm sitting there and i felt you
know what just like
how long ago was this this was like six
seven years ago so i
wow it's like you can't crazy you can't
process what's going
on was he white he was a weirdo and so
you can't process what's going on
because it's like normalcy bias you
would never think somebody would do that
to you yeah so i'm just saying i'm like
and i remember just saying to myself in
my head i go by the time this interview
is done
you're not going to be angry anymore
because time will pass and because the
interview was like 15 minutes and you
have to be
you know in a person not necessarily a
persona but you have to like
be entertaining yeah and so when he so
paul was inside and he was ordering and
after it was done
i just started i stood there at the
corner this is the corner of the street
and by the way larchmont in that area is
loud as [ __ ] was he an older guy no he
was a younger dude
and it was he was with his girlfriend oh
i'm sitting there what a good guy
i'm like i can remember processing all
these thoughts i'm like why would he
think i'm being loud
i'm really far away and on top of that
larchmon is a busy street there's cars
honking it's already loud as [ __ ] so i'm
like
okay cool who the [ __ ] does this guy
think you're so crazy and i'm sitting
there just who goes to a public place
and tells somebody hey you're being
annoying get the [ __ ] out of here
exactly and i'm in your car you [ __ ]
idiot oh yeah you know what what the
[ __ ]
the way he could have approached it to
was simply
hey man like i'm trying to have my meal
you kind of being loud and i would have
been a little irritated but i wouldn't
have been mad
but he said you're being [ __ ]
annoying so it's like oh how many times
has he said this to somebody he got away
with it
and i just kept building this narrative
but also go somewhere
else dude yeah you don't have to sit
there you [ __ ] back off
outside it's outdoor dining busy street
you're back because someone's being loud
at a public
eatery yeah right and i'm not even in
the eating area i'm literally at the
corner near the stoplight so i'm pretty
[ __ ] far away
you know he he obviously can hear me
speak but i wasn't even anywhere near
where
like even further than the length of
this room like really far that guy
probably doesn't like black people
either
and he was like black enough he's my
racist
with your saggy pants yeah yeah and um i
just remember i walked over and it's so
funny because when you guys mentioned
that smile
i did the same smile because i walked
over and i [ __ ] you [ __ ] not
but i walked over to this dude he's mid
bite about to bite his chipotle and i
slapped him upside his head
full [ __ ] force blow burrito
came out his mouth and he just stared he
goes what the [ __ ] and i just looked at
him and i put my hand on his shoulder
and i was smiling
my buddy paul remembers it because he
thought he and i were friends because i
had my hand on his shoulder
you have a real relationship with your
friend because he's sitting outside and
he could just see it but he can't hear
anything so i just had my he said
she's like dude i thought you guys were
friends because you were smiling and you
had your hand on the shoulder
but the context always is important i
was literally telling him i was like
either you sit the [ __ ] down or i'ma
beat the [ __ ] out of you right in front
of your [ __ ] girl
yeah that's all i said and i just kept
smiling at him because i was so
infuriated i couldn't process how angry
i was
i've never had that happen to me before
i was just like sit down or i'm gonna
[ __ ] murder you that's all i just
kept on saying yeah and then his girl
was like
what's your problem he was just telling
you to be quiet and then i remember this
is when you knew i was a crazy person
bro
because [ __ ] nuts the amount of like
who are these people man
oh my god and her saying that made me
even more angry
my friends have you ever tried
kickboxing or boxing before
better yet have you heard of fight camp
my friends because if you haven't
you are missing out you guys know by now
i love boxing and kickboxing and i
actually lost a majority of my weight
because of it and fight camp can bring
you all of this
to your home baby now don't get it
twisted fight camp can be for
absolute beginners or experienced boxers
who want a great workout from home
or just want to level up those boxing or
kickboxing skills it comes with the gear
you need and not
crappy gear either they have one of the
best freestanding punching bags
available
quality gloves wraps and even a punch
tracking sensor so you can see that
speed baby
if you're looking to get off that ass
and find a dope way to gain a new skill
while getting a workout
it's going to be fight camp this could
even be an amazing
holiday gift i would have flipped my
[ __ ] if i received this as a gift no
joke so fight camp
is offering flexible financing for as
low as zero percent apr
and zero dollars down and right now as a
limited time holiday offer
get free shipping and a gift valued up
to a hundred and nine dollars with every
fight camp package just go to
joinfightcamp.com
genius that's right get free shipping
and a gift valued up to 109
with your purchase bring an authentic
boxing and kickboxing gym into your home
with fight camp to get your free gift
just go to joinfightcamp.com genius
that's jointfightcamp.com
genius and so the dude literally sits
down
and i grab a chair and i sit next to him
i was like good now get the [ __ ] out of
here
i told him to get the [ __ ] out bro
you're the golden state killer
you did the most mild version of the
golden state killer and i literally told
this full
like i just remember just going off i
was like you and i are not born in the
same place i was like you're lucky i'm
in a better place right now because i
would literally [ __ ] murder you but i
was like we are not cutting the same
cloth you need to [ __ ] leave see i'll
[ __ ] kill you cause i just never
in my life that somebody could just talk
down to me like that see you know i had
a battle with
i was talking to my buddy kenny about
this and when i told the story he goes
you should have chased that [ __ ]
down and beat his [ __ ] ass and i was
like let's not do that
yeah i know i'm getting he's like no no
he goes
but people have to understand that they
can't be doing this type of [ __ ] to
people
like without without repercussions yeah
and i was like you know what
you're absolutely right that is kind of
true but also there's a middle ground
he's a middle ground yeah i was gonna
beat nobody's ass i love that story and
i was like
everything was like i was like yeah [ __ ]
yeah i'm glad you slapped him glad
you're the hand
you told him crazy cold [ __ ] but then
when you sat down and literally punked
them out of the chair i was like oh
that was like when you got maniac level
but also i feel like
that's very deserved some people don't
think
that like they could do things like that
obviously you could probably say
david went overboard yeah probably
whatever i don't i don't think so
actually
so somebody will say that but only
reason i will say that but i don't think
so my whole thing is is like
when you put that that type of energy
out there when you go to someone
and you're that disrespectful to someone
you don't know at a public restaurant
you deserve to get hit by a car alone
here's why i don't think you went
overboard is because
that guy's actually lucky that you
weren't a real psycho yeah that's how i
always look at it
because i'm like that's what people say
or do weird [ __ ] like that i'm always
like
dude literally i could be a crazy person
who just likes killing people yeah and i
could just
kill you yeah and you're literally
you're taking that chance with me like
i'm not like think
like i i think about it right in a funny
way we talked about it
we just shot this dude but i wouldn't
actually do it because there's guys out
there that are like i just feel like
shooting somebody today
and i think he chose to pick on me
because i'm a fat asian dude goofy
looking guy
once again that's a very common theme
that happens to david right and it's
like
as an asian dude you see this [ __ ]
happen like i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
sit here and be like
you know like when i was looking at my i
was looking at like old pictures of
myself and i was like oh
i don't know why people picked on me
like because i look like the easiest
person
i don't know why he picked on me too
because he thought he could look like he
was gonna do something you know
but then it's like the moment you hear
somebody speak with conviction that
they're gonna murder you it's like
oh he's he's uh not the typical thing
that's a different story yeah and the
reason why i told him
after i told him to sit down was did he
leave he left because the reason why i
told him because
i was getting so angry he had because i
deserve
that sorry yeah well deserved you know
and he had to leave because if he i
couldn't sit there and just watch him
because like i was getting rid of just
[ __ ] it's also like you have to make
a decision like
once again if you bring that type of
energy out to somebody
you better be ready for what's gonna
come that's what i'm saying yeah it
would have been a bad look because my
buddy paul was coming out too
so it was like two you know six foot one
asian dudes it's like
oh this these guys are gonna beat my ass
and yes like i could
to be honest with you that i got so
mad and i had a i remember at that
moment i just moved to la this was like
may actually it was more than seven
years ago probably like eight or eight
years ago
so i just moved to l.a i assaulted a man
eight years ago
i just moved to l.a i wasn't really
comfortable in this space
and i just i had like this very weird
moment where i didn't like a
lot of people that i was meeting in this
city yeah and so i remember i left to
sacramento for three weeks so you're
you're fresh out the hood though
i left the sacramento for three weeks
because uh i was so pissed like i just
wanted to get the [ __ ] out so he was
like
the the straw that broke the camel's
hump and i'm like oh i actually need to
leave
from this area because a week before
that i almost beat up somebody in my
apartment
oh really you have so many stories of
you almost beating
my buddy ed park he was there because he
we lived in the same
park vp no different part of [ __ ] yeah
you know a lot of you know as koreans we
all have the same thing i thought i
wasn't expecting that
yeah so that was the the last those
three things that happened i don't want
to go through the stories but there was
three things that happened and that was
the third thing that happened within
my story where i'm like you know what
i'm just [ __ ] done with the city i
can't deal with people here people
because where i grew up too like you
couldn't just say stuff like nah you
can't there were real consequences so
like
in my mind i just kept telling myself
and this is a really bad thought to have
but it's like
how can you go around say that stuff
without having anything happen to you
yeah because it just doesn't happen like
where i grew up anyways
like if you said something to somebody
but that's how it should be though yeah
that is kind of how i should that's
exactly how it should be
yeah like you you shouldn't have like
for the guy with the
the [ __ ] about the guy with the mask
right if he really had beef with me
sit down and talk to me bro like you you
have beef with me not wearing a mask
let's sit down and talk about it why why
do you think why do you think i should
be wearing a mask right now i'm very
curious yeah and that was my whole thing
so i was like i'm very curious to see
what's going through this [ __ ] kid's
head because i'm sure it was a very
sensitive topic
but at the same time you can't talk to
people
like that and walk away and think
everything's all good
well and also like what was he getting
out of eggs
because he could he was already gone
like it's just like [ __ ] like
in his head he could be like i guess i'm
an [ __ ] for not wearing a mask but
like am i really gonna try to start a
fight right now
over it like i'm already almost in my
car but like he had to go out of his way
to be like hey like i
gotta say something or whatever usually
when that happens in my head i'm like oh
that's a power trip
like the guy that went up to david was
like you're [ __ ] annoying that's a
power trip
and that's something it was so weird
because that's annoying he literally got
out of his [ __ ] seat while he's
eating to come over and say that to me
why crazy what are you out of your
[ __ ] mind like yeah right
argue what did i do to you you know i
mean people live in l.a dog yeah you
think all these people are [ __ ] all
just normal cool people i'm like nah man
you're gonna get a [ __ ] psychopath
every now and then well just keep you
keep running you keep walking around
like that
talking this [ __ ] right you better be
ready
but you're right like how i can't even
imagine
like unless somebody's being like like
you're at a restaurant some guy's
pulling his dick out like ah yeah like
yo bro
but then there's not gonna be just one
person that's like i have a real problem
with that right like everyone's gonna be
like yo what the [ __ ]
but even even if i was in that situation
and i started talking to said guy with
his dick out at the restaurant
i would still be like okay i'm engaging
so i might have to fight this dude yeah
i'm i'm
aware that the the this could happen
even though i'm in the right completely
for being like yeah
exactly exactly but we could still get
in the knife because this guy's crazy
yeah who knows what's going on but like
to just get up
and and like act and then be surprised
that's what i'm that's what i don't get
that's what how are you like okay he
felt
say he felt really annoyed and he went
up to you and said that and then sat
back down
but the beast be like what's your
problem yeah once at like
what what you started some [ __ ] yeah
what's
your fault what the [ __ ] do you think is
yeah this could this is all in the realm
of you've opened the door to the [ __ ]
that could definitely happen now yeah
and his [ __ ] girlfriend's saying like
he just asked you to be quiet it's like
no [ __ ] that's not what he said
he did not even when i think about it i
get mad because i just it just makes me
mad
he's getting red hot right now red hot
or hot just [ __ ] red huh
i think that was awesome too if i look
back at it that was probably the the
the beginning moment where i just
started not going out as much
because of how irritated i would get and
how people would
would talk to other people you know
because i'm so used to everybody just
minding their own business
that's how it should yeah because if you
mind your own business nothing
really happens i say a majority of the
time no you it really doesn't
yeah no yeah everything goes pretty
smoothly i still remember
the he had like that that og bmw 3
series it was bright blue
i still remember what if i saw him on
the street today i would still know what
he looks like
that's how i met his face is imprinted
he had these
he had those [ __ ] the brown and black
ray-bans the the wayfarers you know the
yeah the the spotted one he had is he
wearing glasses
uh sunglasses yeah blonde hair of course
blue and white pinstripe dress shirt
uh [ __ ] uh chambray shorts boat shoes
and a sweater over his shoulder i still
remember
if i saw him in the middle of the street
i would know exactly what he looks like
he's not with his girl anymore because
she dumped his ass probably
you're gonna let him talk to me like
that i was so [ __ ] mad i'm like
sweater over
that's that's crazy too yeah that's
sweater over your shoulder that's a good
that's [ __ ] rap that's like some
terrorist [ __ ] brother
when you see a guy like that you're like
that guy's probably raped like in
somebody in college probably that's what
you think
i honestly want to know how like that's
such an [ __ ] thing to do like
how do you actually go like it's it's
there's there's a lineage of assholeness
associated with this clothing you better
be you better be daniel's area or some
[ __ ] you might have definitely roofied
his sister a couple times
yeah yeah yeah exactly like that full
he's the guy he was the same stanford
swimmer
like i can't even make this [ __ ] he just
had that prototype of that
that douchebag white boy i wish you beat
his ass i'd have been so funny but you
know what though you would have gone to
jail probably
yeah you would you would have gone
because that's the thing it's like you
know what sucks is he could have called
the cops and you actually would have for
sure
you know what to be honest with you
[ __ ] i think he just didn't call my
bluff he probably could have beat my ass
he wasn't a small dude like
he was like a little taller than i was
i'm just you know crazy in your eyes
it's like you know no no but the
thing is people aren't really about it a
lot most people aren't that that's what
he was just a bully
he didn't want to find out what he was
yeah he folded it he was like oh yeah
yeah that'd be so funny i did all this
[ __ ] he beats my ass i'm like oh not
exactly who i said i was but that's a
cool story still though
that's a great story dude yeah i like
that those are just weird
moments you changed his life for sure i
hope he doesn't talk to people like that
because that's terrible
i'm sure he thinks about it at least i
remember that one time that [ __ ] fat
asian guy was beating my ass
i was like yeah yeah almost did yeah
some people that should stick with you
it should unless you're a [ __ ] idiot
yeah dude people are [ __ ] nuts yeah i
just don't get angry the audacity of
people you know i definitely don't get
angry like that anymore because i think
now
with how i am if that happened i
wouldn't do that anymore i would just i
would honestly probably just let it go
yeah yeah because i just know the
consequences i have a lot to lose now
right somebody just told me like i'm
being [ __ ] annoying i think i just
probably just eat a lot of dairy and
fart around them
i do like very petty [ __ ] now yeah like
the threatening stuff doesn't matter
because also i'm concerned that
everybody's an mma fighter
i'm like yeah i bet you this what if if
he took off his boat shoes and i'm like
uh
this guy does muay thai he's like like
the thai music hold on there you go
that'd be so funny
and it turns out that guy turned out to
be joe shilling oh [ __ ] no
i'm crazy and then he beats my [ __ ]
ass jesus
well guys well let's get into the genius
advice yeah
sorry let's get into some advice for you
guys yeah yeah don't be an [ __ ] guys
yeah just be nice to people okay yeah
thank god he didn't beat my ass he
called a [ __ ] he could have called the
cops out of big trouble
[ __ ] that guy yeah [ __ ] that guy i'm
pretty sure he just got scared because
my buddy paul walked out too so he was
like oh there's two guys here no i think
it was it was the fact that he
understood that you were like [ __ ]
[ __ ] your ass up and it's serious like a
lot of people
aren't really trying to get in a fight
like that i don't just want to say [ __ ]
to you
and look cool and they can get away with
it yeah and get away with it that's why
the dudes that are really about it don't
do that because they don't need to do
that
imagine if [ __ ] like francis and
ghana went up to somebody which is
like he would never do that i remember
there was another dude eating uh
eating his little chipotle little
burrito bowl outside it was really
[ __ ] fat old white dude with like a
he had a black uh
collar shirt short sleeve and like
khakis and he just sat there just eating
his food just looking over like
should i say something he was like i
just remember i'm thinking like if you
say something i'ma [ __ ] your ass up too
cause you're probably on his side
harassed as [ __ ] man yeah mind your
business dude
yeah mine's your business you don't know
what happens man you stay over there
this this that ain't is
that's the deal davidson yeah this ain't
it guys you stole my wallet
carry on all right
hi there party
so uh gb podcast advice uh
since we're gonna read this out loud and
i haven't read it yet uh we're gonna
leave the name out we're gonna call this
guy
uh peter gonzalez peter goes out
never met one before but i'm pretty sure
there's one out there peter yeah hey
david first off i just want to say thank
you for consistently uploading despite
all the craziness going on in the world
awesome this podcast has become one of
the things i look forward to
stop complimenting me let's just go
straight to the advice because i'm
feeling too good right now
so i took up hiking a couple of years
ago and it's something that i've
since come to love awesome found this
passion and outlet for stress and
anxiety has really helped turn my uh
around my depression all right and with
the plans and with the plans i have for
future hikes i feel like for the first
time in a long time i have something to
look forward to
damn bro your life was bleak the goal
right now
is to get ready for the pacific crest
trail in 2022
wow the trail is 2650 miles long
jesus christ starting at the mexican
border
and ending at the canadian border
dude that's like a voyage an odyssey
dude that's a manifest destiny
oh [ __ ] you got to hire this lady named
seca joao
yeah so dc is [ __ ] dude that's like you
gotta fight a cyclops or some [ __ ] my
man's about to find the meaning of life
yo that's wild as [ __ ] bro dude yeah wow
peter goes on as you're killing him
is it even possible the problem is the
trail takes four to six months to come
to complete that's a big problem this
would throw a serious wrench in my
career plans oh yeah
uh he just leaves his job yeah by the
way i'm walking did he say what he does
for a living
not yet i'm a semester away from getting
my prerequisites completed to be able to
apply to
a nursing program okay if i finish my
last semester in may
of 2021 that would give me time around
until april of 2022 to save money and
seriously train
for the hike first of all i'm gonna [ __ ]
you train for something like this
i would not be able to apply to any
nursing programs my parents are very
much against this since they believe
that if i were to take that much time
off school there's a good chance i won't
finish what i started
i could possibly lose being on my
parents health insurance if i'm 21 and
not a full-time student
i know they're looking out for me and i
totally understand their reasoning doing
the hike would
make my future more uncertain what i do
know is that not doing the hike would be
something i'll regret for the rest of my
life i'm healthy now
and given my family medical history i
don't want to take the chance
because i don't know if i'll stay
healthy and wait until after nursing
school
which will most likely be longer i guess
my questions for you are is the hike as
a bad of an idea as my family has told
me is doing something i love worth the
risk of an uncertain future and not
finishing why was he saying stuff about
he won't be healthy enough to do it
later in his life i don't know i think
right now
he i think he's just on a roll you know
like when you get hyped up
when you feel like you're you're doing
something 100 it's either
strike while the iron's hot or it's
never going to happen well
there's going to be a weird moment for
for you where if this is something that
you really want to do a lot of the times
especially because you're a lot younger
you think that your age is a factor for
why you can't complete things yeah and
that's really not the case i
i mean when i started kickboxing when i
was like what 29
right 29 now i'm like 32 so yeah
2017 right yeah yeah roughly around
there so it's been about like three
years
and i started really [ __ ] late but
you know i i don't have a
grandeur of being like an amazing
kickboxer but it's something that i do
for fun
if this is a goal life that you want to
set you could do it later on in life
after nursing school definitely yeah
it's i don't understand why it's
really uh pertinent for you to do it now
unless you're dying yeah that's the
thing too it's like
the more time like this is gonna take
four to six months to complete
you probably need like this podcast is
brought to you by hawthorne how many of
you out there care about your self-care
if you don't you should because smelling
looking and feeling your best is where
hawthorne
comes in i know for a lot of us out
there when it comes to lotions and
deodorants and face washes you might not
know where to start
well screw all of that get stuff custom
tailored to match you perfectly all you
got to do is take a fun quiz by
hawthorne to get that customized
self-care bundle made just for you
it's probably one of the easiest things
i've ever done to get the best results
you're going to be surprised
how accurate these products are for
matching your hair skin and body which
normally takes so much trial and error
to figure out you got to buy a bunch of
products you don't know what's going to
happen
well good skin and hair and smell comes
easy with hawthorn
and if you're lonely it's probably
because your skin is ashy and you stink
so let hawthorne hook you up
yes stinky smelly face person genius
brain listeners do what i did take
hawthorne's quiz today and get started
on your personalized self-care routine
by going to hawthorne.co
and use promo code brain to get 10 off
your first purchase that's
h a h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e dot c-o
promo code brain that's hawthorne.co
promo code brain
more than a couple years to train for
this unless you're david goggins i don't
know how
like i don't know anything about
necessarily like hiking long distance
like that but i would imagine
it's very physically punishing right
because you have to carry all your [ __ ]
so it's obviously a lot of walking a lot
of extra load on
your body right so i would imagine that
you training for something like this is
this is not something that you take very
lightly this is you you take this very
seriously
because honestly if i mean he's on his
last semester of nursing school bro
you're to have to train a lot longer
yeah so while you're in nursing school
finish up
train for this for a solid year and then
you'll be better prepared there's
nothing
definitely definitely you're in a mind
state right now where you think you're
on this crazy time crunch and you're not
unless you're you didn't tell us about
something that you have like a physical
ailment
you know right so i don't this is it's a
weird concept where everybody feels like
time is
like you can't do things and i feel like
that's very strong in someone that's
like
20 early 20s because i feel like i have
the same thing too it's like you feel
like time is constantly running out
but as you get into your like your later
20s or whatever like that
that's when you're really starting to
feel like that's like the true prime
you know it's like yeah like 20 is when
you kind of make mistakes and you kind
of like do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do
whatever and by the way too man you i
get you have you been listening to a lot
of david goggins you don't got to be
like him
that was a [ __ ] maniac yeah you know
what that fool did recently
he got hit up on wednesday before
thanksgiving by a friend that says hey
let's do a 200 mile [ __ ] uh race and
he goes
got it no prep and he does starts the
race on thursday
damn wednesday one [ __ ] day
and he completes a 200 mile [ __ ] race
but to his like
his credit though he's probably been
training he runs like every day
every day have you seen that picture of
that man's toes
uh yeah destroyed yeah look it up do you
know what
balot looks like the the duck fetus
look a picture of [ __ ] balot and then
his [ __ ] toes
exactly the same a duck fetus disgusting
yeah
they're just demolished there's [ __ ]
david goggins feet i'm gonna get some
i might i might jerk off to this later
baby come on look at that ew
dude yeah does that [ __ ] looks
disgusting it does look like balloon
it looks like duck fetus she's nasty
look at that this is so toenail is
completely gone what the [ __ ] that's
like a bunion bro like jesus christ
you ever wake up and you don't got
kneecaps
well i say [ __ ] kneecaps i don't get
hard i'm like
what are you saying right now man this
makes no sense dude even navy seals are
like yo this guy's [ __ ] nuts yeah
i'm pretty sure navy seals are like he
didn't have to finish uh that [ __ ] like
five times
yeah he absolutely didn't have to i
don't know why yeah that was a full trip
that dude's [ __ ]
he's what he's like in his mid 40s too
he looks great yeah he does yeah
he's a beast dude he's a [ __ ] lean as
[ __ ] he has like two percent body fat
i think uh either way you guys are right
like it's like there's no rush because
it's like he could do this later he
could he could do nursing school do it
afterwards
or however the the puzzle pieces fit
together best for like the outcome that
he needs
but even if um even if he decided to do
it now i mean he would get the backlash
from his family
and i don't think it's the hike i don't
think is as bad as his family's making
it seem yeah yeah because it's just a
[ __ ] hike and if he's serious about
my uh my best friend this fool might die
on this [ __ ] yeah my best friend he
actually uh went to
so before he i guess you're right
yeah good point before he
applied to med school he's a doctor now
he went to ecuador for two years
uh and he uh applied to the peace corps
nice so yeah
you know i could see he's kind of doing
that route and for him
there's no time crunch yeah right right
exactly he was probably one of the older
people in his class when he went to med
school because he took like two or three
years off to do the stuff that he wanted
so i understand his point of view
and effort went to ecuador for two years
he came back flew it in spanish did he
say he
he just got into high school i guess he
just got done he just got inside
okay got it so if try a thousand mile
hike first
exactly like like try something that's
not
as treacherous because i feel like once
you start this
there's no coming back from this yeah so
make sure you're very well prepared for
the hike because this isn't
something i crazy progression like he
starts super happy two months later he
runs out of money
yeah three months later he's sucking
dick on the side of the road yeah
yeah yeah yeah he ends up in a hotel
it's terrible it's one thing if you're
you know going abroad or traveling
abroad or whatever the [ __ ] but you're
going into the wilderness for four
thousand plus miles
two thousand six hundred something yeah
what's the longest hike he's done so
it's can't be yes
what's the longest hike you've done six
miles like okay chill
yeah yeah relax yeah yeah work your way
up start slow yeah and kind of work your
way up right right you know what you can
do
because it's a zero-sum goal right
something that you do for yourself
same dude my best friend he he likes to
take vacations the way nobody likes to
take vacations which is just pain
so he went he went on this this trail in
spain i forgot what it's called it's
called
spit of the death death walker that's on
the death wall
i forgot what it's called but it's worth
it
it's like it's nice i don't know i mean
people can tell me what this is because
i'm pretty sure it's really popular but
it's like a spiritual walk that you do
in spain okay and i think like the i
forgot how long the full trek is like a
hundred and something miles
but then you could choose to do 20 or 30
or 40 or 50 miles of it
and he could start there i heard that
[ __ ] was my my buddy did that [ __ ] dude
his toes were
[ __ ] up dude really he did the whole
thing yeah he tried to get me to do it
dumb ass you gotta work your way up to
that [ __ ] and it's like you're in the
wild too
right where is he walking where's the
where mexican border
canadian border through like cities and
[ __ ] or like is he like along the coast
i mean i guess like other people have
done it before it's like a trailer
there's a trailer
and i'm assuming you need money to do
this
for sure or you know how to suck that
dick on the road man yeah either way
both works both work [ __ ] dick will
get you but i would say give yourself a
little more
time to prep because it does seem like
prep for a [ __ ] 3000 mile walk well
you gotta i feel like you got to get
your body
acclimated to that like not only are you
i'm assuming
i don't know i don't know [ __ ] about
hiking but like you're also going to
different elevations too
just every day i have somebody beat your
legs to death with a bat yeah
that's like your training regimen
break your [ __ ] femur and [ __ ] you
know because even 100 miles is what like
santa barbara from here that
imagine walking in santa barbara that's
crazy and you're gonna hit different
terrain right there you know so
i don't think i've ever trained
physically for something that hard in my
life like i wouldn't know what that
feels like yeah bro that's crazy
that's a lot of [ __ ] yeah maybe don't do
it bro just go to nurses
i'll say it is i say like for something
that big i feel like you have to work
your way
like [ __ ] their first big trail
that they hit isn't
like if you're a climber the first one
you're not gonna do is mount everest bro
like yeah i mean like yeah
you're gonna work your way up to it
you're like okay you know what now i'm
gonna climb that [ __ ] mountain
i've never done a marathon never ever
trained for anything physically in my
life
because i don't see the point
i'm like yeah it has to be enjoy even
when i bike it has to be enjoyable like
yeah
because sometimes too when people like
some of my friends they they notice that
i'm biking they're like hey man we're
about to hit this 40
40 mile trek and i'm like hey man go
kill yourself i'm not going to drive in
the car
are you trying to kill yourself like
literally that's nuts
why why why would i do this so like dude
it's like when you go up
that [ __ ] 20 miles up it's hard but
20 miles down you feel like you're free
and i'm like
the dumbest thing i've ever heard in my
life you shut the [ __ ] up yeah you tell
me i have to go 20 miles
uphill hell [ __ ] no yeah because it's
not fun for me at that time 20 feet
uphill is pretty rough too
that is pretty rough i can't do it i
literally can't i what i bought today i
biked
close to 20 miles and that [ __ ] was
exhausting as [ __ ] your boy's legs are
linguini right now
yeah that's a lot i can't do [ __ ] that's
a lot yeah so next week we're hitting 25
baby
come on dog see it let's get a bike
don't you have a bike made for like a
[ __ ] eight-foot person
yeah get a real bike you do well it's it
was like tiff's
it was in tiff's garage her mom's garage
and she was like hey i take the bike and
i was like okay
and then my my buddy joe who's a avid
bike rider was like oh yeah this bike is
like big for you
he's like you're going to fall off of it
because you suck and i was like okay
it's like a he has like a 57
58 centimeter frame and that's on the
bigger side for me
damn yeah so i could probably ride like
a 54 centimeter frame right but i choose
the 57 to 58 because it's a little more
comfortable like in terms of riding
position
yeah i'm more of a 48 35 so do your feet
touch the pedals or
i haven't tried wow can you ride a bike
uh
can you read can you define rig
i don't know i don't know nick i didn't
learn how to
ride a bike until i was 11. really what
why
i just i was just i'm i'm gonna i think
i'm a late bloomer and everything
everything were you not curious when
your friends were just riding circles
around well like i would ride tricks
we'll meet you there nick i would
literally i would literally ride with
training wheels all the time like that's
you were 11. bro like now you see you
you deserve to get bullied
yeah no for sure i would have bullied
your ass
i stand behind that it wasn't until my
grandma for my left this is the only
reason i remember this my grandma got me
a scooter a razor
nice for my 11th birthday and i was like
oh [ __ ] and i learned how to balance on
it and then i got on the bike the next
day and i was like oh [ __ ] i can ride a
bike now
so it was i don't know if that i don't
know if i'm just stupid
or if those skills actually translate
but that's how i learned how to ride a
bike pretty sad
next topic you know how i learned how to
write like that's the most traumatizing
experience of my life my dad tried doing
that to me and he'd realize like oh my
son's a [ __ ]
i wish my dad was like that so there's
two ways that i learned how to do things
so i first learned how to swim
when i when i was in sacramento i used
to live in this place called tem woods
and it was a duplex it was kind of like
hood and little ghetto there's like trap
houses every [ __ ] corner
sorry but there was a community pool
that was in the area and i grew up with
a kid who had a lot of anxiety and fear
so i think because my dad had those
qualities
in himself he hated seeing that in me so
he would always try to beat the [ __ ] out
of me
to beat that out of my system and it
worked right yeah
does that work it does not work yeah so
i would um
like so i remember at the community pool
that we used to swim at that i actually
enjoyed swimming a lot i actually love
swimming now
but this bull taught me by telling me to
walk next to the edge of the pool and he
literally [ __ ] kicked me in the back
and i flew in and then i started
freaking out
i remember just screaming hell but water
was going into my lungs and [ __ ]
and i just [ __ ] paddled all the way
to the edge of the thing crying and go
see
you didn't die and that's how he taught
me how to swim wow but it worked
it worked it didn't work now he taught
me how to [ __ ] run him right is that
what the same thing is from that's
literally exactly where it comes from
you know this taught me how to ride a
[ __ ] bike
traumatizing dude when i look back obama
hill so
i was so scared of riding a bike and i
used to always ride with training wheels
right and if i was living at the duplex
at the time i couldn't have been more
than
the age of six or seven six six seven
around there so
a way earlier than me yeah yeah because
i'm a normal kid
right and i wanted friends so yeah so
i i wouldn't ride the bike without the
training wheels and so my dad got so
[ __ ] upset at me
i [ __ ] you not it was like midnight i
don't know the exact time but it was
pitch black outside it was a
thunderstorm in sacramento raining
i'm talking about thunder like boom
lightning coming down yeah dragged me
out of my [ __ ] bed
took me outside while it's raining grab
the [ __ ] bike without the tricycle
wheels he goes
right you either ride this bike or
you're not going inside
and so i'm outside he waited for the
storm
he was telling your mom like listen well
he was trying to teach me how to ride
that day and he got so frustrated
my mom was like go inside it's raining
we'll teach him another time
he was already trying to teach me how to
ride this without training wheels for
about a couple of weeks okay i just
wouldn't do it because i was so scared
so he literally threatened to beat my
[ __ ] ass until i learned how to ride
this bike
so i just remember i could still
remember till this day crying and
the rain mixing it with the tears
this rain is salty
i just but i learned how to ride the
bike that day i learned after that day i
could ride the bike
wow but he would not let me go inside
the house until i could ride the bike
so parents at home if you're listening
twice
here if you're teaching your kid how to
ride a bike and they can't wait for a
giant rainstorm yeah
and that's how you do it wait for zeus
to throw thunderbolts
and then my dad waited for the lightning
but he goes is it dangerous outside he
puts a lightning rod in the back of your
phone
you go faster i actually have
superpowers guys
if you don't ride a bike you die
that's what he was saying to me legit
wow remember that [ __ ] like it was
yesterday just
yelling at me keep going
like in korean just keep going
don't stop or you don't have a dinner
just like yelling at me you want a water
for dinner
at the boy i'm like
but i remember when i finally tried it
it works bro my mom came out and started
[ __ ]
cursing my dad out he's are you [ __ ]
crazy
it's raining outside he needs to learn
and i'm like
but smooth as [ __ ] wow perfect
everyone in the neighborhood is like yo
that family loves bike riding they take
this [ __ ] seriously
you're gonna be there
give me your ball that's enough he
taught me
he definitely hated seeing weakness in
us because
when i found out later on in life was
that my dad didn't
he also hated these qualities about
himself but he hated seeing the
qualities that he saw in his own father
so my grandpa quick like long story
short the most like
dad [ __ ] ever yeah so he's trying to
correct these behaviors that he hates
seeing
so he might my grandpa actually used to
be pretty wealthy
uh he was an owner of this like
tupperware factory so
my grandpa had this habit of kind of
being too nice and trusting other people
to do things right so he wasn't very
knowledgeable about his own stuff
long story short with that he went
bankrupt all of his partners stole all
this [ __ ] money
so my dad has always had trust issues
with people so when he sees like that
type of weakness like fragility in
somebody
he hated that [ __ ] it made him angry and
obviously he took it out on us
yeah but it just turned out that his kid
had mad [ __ ] anxiety he didn't know
how to deal with it like
ordering food i couldn't do that [ __ ] i
couldn't talk to people
but i was a really goofy kid but when it
came to interacting with new people
i [ __ ] sucked at that [ __ ] so
whenever he saw me do something that he
thought was terrible
that he thought was a bad trait to have
because he was scared that i was going
to end up like his father
yeah he was so severe about it so he
would either like beat my ass or make me
do extreme things that i didn't want to
do
yeah like going to the store and working
at the store and having to deal with
customers yeah my brother didn't have to
deal with that but i had to deal with it
all the time but it turned out to be a
great skill later on yeah sure yeah but
you know but it was torture in the
moment he could have done it other ways
you know how did you figure all this out
did you talk to him about it or your mom
told you because my dad doesn't talk
about the stuff
my mom is like his translator so she'll
say like hey remember when you were a
kid and you would you know this it was
because
you know your your grandpa was such a
fuck-up so he hated seeing that and he
was a and you were a scared kid you were
scared of
everything you didn't want to do [ __ ] so
when i tell these kids sometimes when
you guys ask for advice and you're
asking me well
how did you do this like you know it's
not easy for me because you know you
could go and talk to anybody you do
stand up i'm like
that [ __ ] had to i had to work on that
really hard yeah right
i was frightened of the world like i
just did you know what's true though is
like because i felt
like i felt like that way when i was a
kid too like i was very shy
i wouldn't talk to anybody and i was
like kind of afraid to talk to people
but with that being like being afraid of
that it kind of teaches you how to be
like
okay well i gotta do something about it
and it kind of actually the weaknesses
actually kind of
make you turn that into strengths after
after a period of time you know
even with the with my my dad didn't like
the way i got bullied and i got bullied
i understood why
not easy target yeah so i would have
done the same if i if i was now and i
went back in time i saw myself
i would have taken my lunch money for
sure but uh
my dad wouldn't let me go back home
until i confronted the people who
bullied me
so i wasn't allowed to come back home
yeah like i remember
getting [ __ ] jacked for me or stolen and
my dad would be like where's your stuff
he goes oh they took it from me he goes
cool well closes the door when you get
your stuff back come back home
so i'm like oh what the [ __ ] am i
supposed to do so that's when david
grabbed the pencil
went to the kid stabbed him in the face
and he was like what happened
this podcast is brought to you by cbd
farmhouse if you haven't heard of cbd
farmhouse
well you will very soon because cbd
farmhouse when it comes to their
products stands out above the rest
and i'm not just saying that because i
actually use a lot of their products
before they became a sponsored brand i
was actually using them even before that
so
the the freezing roll-on is money
specifically if you're sore or if you
have some kind of eggs i use it all the
time specifically i kick box and i work
out
and that has been a savior if you
haven't had their gummies
use it when you're uh feeling anxious if
you have anxiety attacks a lot
cbd gummies are a godsend and on top of
that if i just want to sleep really well
i eat one of the gummies right before i
sleep and it just helps me to
relax if you're getting this stuff
before december 15th they actually have
a really great
deal on holiday bundles that you can get
for yourself or give out as a gift
and it's super discounted as it is but
if you're not
check it out for all my genius brain
listeners you can get
15 off any order if you just plug in
codebrain at checkout that's at
cbdfarmhouse.com
once again cbdfarmhouse.com
and use codebrain to get 15 off today
yeah i said that i think that's i mean i
think it sounds like your dad was a
little extreme with it but
i think that's definitely the right way
to go too because in life like you have
to
because bullying doesn't stop in
elementary school there's bullies in the
adult world all the time
and if you let people walk all over you
then you aren't going to have [ __ ]
yeah so i mean that does need to be
instilled in something but
but when i got older too that's what i
started to figure out because i used to
have this really
bad habit of punching [ __ ] when i get
angry and i still have the walls
breaking stuff right so but later on i
started becoming smarter with my mouth
so that's when it was like you know if
you could demoralize another human being
with your words
right when that's when you win right
it's way better than beating somebody's
ass right yeah right because even if i
got into i still felt bad because i felt
barbaric it's like you know
i couldn't just talk the [ __ ] as you get
older you realize like that's not an
option anymore like you can't always
just beat the [ __ ] up yeah right right
like when you're a kid
you're in a cool like you're in a bubble
where it's like
kind of okay to do things like this not
okay but like
it's not necessarily the most frowned
upon but as you get older there's a lot
more
you know consequences like going to jail
yeah
in junior high i remember the time where
i was like
it kind of clicked in my head i was like
hey you could just kind of just roast
people and tell them to shut the [ __ ] up
without having to get in the fistfights
yeah there's this dude his name was
sean baker big old black kid right and
[ __ ] thought he had jokes by the
way sean baker you owe me a dollar
because you borrowed it from me
and you had got that frootopia then you
move school so that's why you you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] you shawn baker he was a big
ass dude though i was like
when i was like in eighth grade so he
was like even taller than me that
big ass [ __ ] he actually looked
like biggie but
this dude in class roasted my ass with
this [ __ ] comment that got
that made everybody laugh it was so
stupid but the crowd behind you was hard
yeah yeah it's because we were learning
about like the it was a history
teacher and he was he was talking about
[ __ ] jaundice or something right and
you're like john as your eyes get yellow
and
and you have like your skin gets yellow
right and he and he just said something
light like he was like
he's like well david had john his whole
life this boy yellow as [ __ ]
and the whole that's fine started
laughing and i know i'm like roman [ __ ]
when he said that [ __ ] i you know
everybody was laughing and he just
called me like
jaundice because they like yellow eyes
and also there's stuff there's some [ __ ]
like that
jonas is the one you got yellow eyes
right yeah yeah yeah
can't you like turn yellow too yeah or
some [ __ ] like that but it was through
your eyes
it was that disease that he was trying
to make fun of so when i came in the
next
class like for like a couple weeks he
kept on calling me john this and he's
like a big dude
like he probably beat my ass right and
so i just kept thinking like man i gotta
i gotta one up this floor everybody's
gonna just keep laughing at me in class
and so finally
we were talking class and i remember
this joke man i felt so good
we were learning um about africa or some
[ __ ] right
and there was like a national geographic
picture right and i was like i looked
and in the middle of class i go look
it's sean baker's family picnic
everybody starts dying laughing no like
and that's the thing it's like
like growing up i was never the best
like i wasn't a roaster i wasn't
roasting people but like
you have to have something you're gonna
have something you gotta say something
there was one kid that used to always
make fun of me
but he would always say like asian jokes
like oh look a lampshade or whatever and
then like
he was kind of like dirty like we would
always make like we would always make
fun of them
so like you know we i made a stupid joke
about a garbage truck drill but i was
like hey
look michael your your mom's coming to
pick you up and get
killed at the time and the teacher was
like that's perspective she was like
how dare you but like everybody like i
remember when i were kids too is like
i was like i was probably one of like
three asian kids in like about
elementary school so anytime somebody
would say china or like
i remember there was a gong that would
go off sometimes like i'm like tv i
forgot what the [ __ ] it was
but all the kids would look and turn at
me and they would like look at me like
yeah i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] well
we had a lot of asian
kids in our school so that wasn't
happening too much it was like it was
like 70
asian and the rest was like black all
the schools oh actually except for my
middle school but like
i was i was always kind of like that
token there's an asian person there you
know like you know
but the word battles killed because he
[ __ ] up and the reason why he lost
that exchange was because
he got mad and he was pulling the race
card he was like he's saying racist [ __ ]
to me right
and the teacher was like a really cool
teacher he goes you know last week you
literally pulled your eyes back and
called him yellow eyes so he goes like
you got to let it go
yeah teacher was really dope he's like
if you're going to say that stuff to him
you can't you can't and then everybody
was clowning on him because he [ __ ]
tattletailed to the teacher he's like
what the [ __ ]
yeah and i was like oh words are way
better than [ __ ] writing somebody
yeah because it hurt his feelings so bad
that he actually told on me to the
teacher and the teacher was like
you just [ __ ] made ching chong jokes
at him last year
so he's like no we're not but that's not
racist yeah and then
we asked we had to apologize to each
other after i'm sorry for calling saying
your family is
african yeah but you still owe me my
dollar for that fruitopia [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] will come for that
dollar yeah david is not me if you can
cut somebody up with your words that's
that's the [ __ ]
my problem was always i would get too
mad like i can playfully joke around but
like that when when if i knew someone
was really trying to [ __ ] with me i
would just
like the heat oh like the time like [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] like i would just get mad at the
time you beat the [ __ ] out of that guy
at the uh at the santa barbara party
because he
said you were gay and you're like what
the [ __ ] you're saying to me you're
beating me i love [ __ ] yeah but
i love [ __ ] love it no it's because he
said he was joking he was like [ __ ] that
like i was like what was the joke and he
was like oh you guys are [ __ ]
it's like oh sick joke bro
well we gotta fight now well that was
that was a death calling card back in
the day if you call somebody the f word
yeah it was done it's like oh you got to
fight that yeah well yeah
yeah that's a that's a i think that's
fair that's very good fairy game
those are fighting words that's the
thing yeah bro you you say anything to
you say an insult to somebody that you
don't really know that well just be
ready to [ __ ] fight yeah you're ready
or make it real
it's got to be it's got you got to know
how to dance on that line you know so
very few people are dying you're like
wait what is this [ __ ] not many people
know how to
do that though yeah like real banter
like a charm
yeah so let's just not fight let's just
be people i don't want to fight anybody
i think when
there's so much more uh stories of
fighting when you're younger because
when you're younger you don't care
yeah like all these same all these fight
stories are all like when you're super
young
now i'm scared shitless i don't know if
somebody has a gun i don't know if
they're a trained [ __ ] fighter
because you're an adult and you know
that like oh these are possibilities now
right there's just too much to lose yeah
too much to lose i can't imagine like me
being in the middle of the street
if somebody calls me a little [ __ ] and
i just start throwing at it i'm just
like yeah i'll just go
yeah yeah yeah i'm like nice dude
whatever walk away with it yeah and
that's a mature adult
well i think when you get older you
don't have as much ego yeah like when
you're young it's all about ego and
bravado for some people right you want
well you just took [ __ ] huh yeah
that would happen that's me
yeah no actually yeah that was me that
was me we'll start playing the asian
flute
you're like
like hey guys look and they're like i'm
just gonna have to do that pull my eyes
back i don't have to do that
but like like when i first started
dealing with that kind of stuff as like
a like in high school because i was like
very different because in middle school
i would just be like all right well i'm
gonna fight you and i would try to like
fight people
and then middle school in high school i
was like all right i probably can't get
away with this [ __ ] because i weigh 105
pounds
and i can't be fighting people so i just
was like all right well let me just
try to be a likable guy so nobody would
make fun of me and i was like it kind of
didn't work out and everyone beat my ass
anyway
no but no one was like like like that's
me when i was in high school or like my
freshman year yeah but after that i was
like
[ __ ] dude yeah i was a little [ __ ]
still am baby
still a [ __ ] till this day because
sometimes i don't realize when someone's
like oh you were talking [ __ ] like you
were kind of being a dick and i
i when i sit down and think about it
afterwards i'm like oh yeah that guy was
trying to be an [ __ ] to me
but eventually like all you have to do
all you have to do is just be like hey
[ __ ] you and they'll be like okay my bad
yeah or they'll just they won't do it
anymore dude you know what just
threatens somebody you know when we talk
about that whole thing where sometimes
like
i feel you know we have these moments
where somebody comes at us and we feel
like we're getting bullied because we're
you know typically asian people tend to
be a lot more quiet and very nice
if i was going to pick on anybody that's
from any race it would
it would probably be asian people racist
i don't give a [ __ ] who you are
i don't know if i'm a bully and i'm like
i'm a pick on somebody i'm gonna be like
oh i'm gonna
this guy's not gonna say anything to me
most of the time i'm like hey foreign
like you could say this [ __ ] all day and
most of the time they'll probably be
like
they probably won't say [ __ ] this is so
my buddy ed was talking about this time
he was at ikea and
he had this is like a small example of
it he had a shopping cart
and he you know walked away for a second
or whatever something happened but this
guy walked and he just took his cart
from him and he's like
what the [ __ ] and and then ed walks up
to me goes hey that's my
cart [ __ ] and the guy looks he just
laughs he laughs at me just walks away
yeah
and you know ed is just like in shock
and he's he's a relatively nice guy
and he's just pissed and fuming and then
our buddy dan he's half white half green
but he looks full
white and it's like yeah this guy
[ __ ] stole our sh
our cart and dan's like who that guy and
then looks and he goes
hey [ __ ] you right but then he walks up
to danny goes hey my bad man i don't
know and he apologizes to dan
but he [ __ ] laughs at ed's face yeah
exactly and see that's the [ __ ] that
we're talking about it's like
if if ed was this white guy would he
have done the same but it was and it was
the same situation and dan was way more
aggressive
yeah but he looks at danny goes i'm
sorry man i apologize like i didn't know
it was yours but to ed
he tells him to go [ __ ] off and he
laughs at his face so that's like those
moments where you see like
oh you think we're like a bunch of
[ __ ] that's what it is like most
people think that
you know it's true like and that's why
i had to punch that dude in the face
because he was trying to bully me yeah
yeah
i remember in high school there was a
buddy of mine who i was actually like
good friends with like we were friends
and i remember i just i was like pissed
or something and he was sitting in my
seat and i was hey bro get the [ __ ] out
my seat like
let me sit this is my seat and we almost
like fought in the [ __ ] classroom
but i remember i was so mad and think
going thinking back on i was i would
have probably just been like
whatever who gives a [ __ ] like now yeah
but back then i was like yo get the [ __ ]
out of my seat bro and this is a guy
that i'm still like pretty chummy with
to this day
but i remember like almost getting in a
fight with this fool and then he was
like all right just to [ __ ] take your
seat down dude
but at first he was like nah man what
the [ __ ] and i was like no [ __ ] you bro
get the [ __ ] out of my seat like you
know it's my [ __ ] seat [ __ ]
like i sit here every [ __ ] day like
why are you now you want to take it you
know i was getting mad
he's one we stepped outside i was like
yeah let's step [ __ ] outside then you
know and he was like all right
just take the chair man we're still
cooling like yeah he called my bluff
but it was just like it was it was
stupid we both realized like oh wait
this is dumb
yeah you know but the fact that i was
even like
the [ __ ] out of here man you know yeah
he was like okay well
all right then somebody's like weird
bullying moments even in junior high i
can remember everyone's testing the
waters yeah they always are
there's well this guy actually ended up
in jail he's been there for a while he
might have killed me but
his name tree frog the tree frog his
name was shaka
hassan wow but he was like uh this dude
flunked like a gajillion time so i think
he was like 30
in seventh grade nice but you know he
was he didn't grow to be that big but i
remember he was trying to steal my uh
he was trying to make copy off of my
homework but he didn't ask he just kind
of took the paper he goes hey i'm gonna
use this real quick
wow i might just [ __ ] snatch it out
of his hand i'm like the [ __ ] are you
doing you know i'll beat your [ __ ]
ass but you know like i said i was like
already like five ten five nine at like
seventh grade so
that's where i stood up and i was just
towering over and i'm like what the [ __ ]
are you doing you know
and i just snatched it right back and it
was just one of that moments where i was
like
[ __ ] why does everybody keep trying to
punk me and it was that weird it's that
weird balance of being a nice guy and
not being a pushover
yeah right and that's that hard balance
because obviously if
if i showed you a picture of what i
looked like in seventh and eighth grade
everybody would have bullied me
it's very easy yeah cause i was so goofy
too i never really caused a lot of
trouble
yeah but obviously i'm not gonna let
somebody just
punk me like that because it it'll
happen consistently for the whole like
eighth grade would have been a nightmare
for me if i just always let it happen
of course and even times most of the
times too i had to stand up even though
i was gonna get my ass beat
i just had to do it i feel like that was
the age for a lot of people like there
was a turning point right it's either
and same with me like seventh eighth
grade i got a lot of people like trying
to like test me
a lot and to the point where i was like
i didn't know what to do
to the point where i was like all right
well i have to start like i just i gotta
get my ass beat i gotta do like
i have to like fight these like i have
to like to harm these people i have to
do something
like one of my buddies who was actually
a good friend of mine like going into
like
seventh grade i think and he was he was
the kid that would go to school there
and
i was new right but he would like he
would [ __ ] like this full had big ears
too
but he would clown on my [ __ ] ears
like that's hilarious like yo you
[ __ ] sad like two years you get
directv with those things with his own
ears yeah
big ass he he was the big year guy
before i got there right yeah
thank god yeah and then and then he
would like clown on me all the time and
i was like yo i thought we were [ __ ]
like homies bro but he
would take your bros for life yeah yeah
and then to the point where i was like
i'm not the [ __ ] like and one time
like i
i like i j like he he said some [ __ ] he
caught me like a chick or some [ __ ]
like i tackled him and i was like trying
to like i was like giving him dead legs
it stopped and it was cool and then more
people tried doing it
and then i had to like do that to them
too and i was like it's that weird
moment where you just have to let
you guys just let people know you you're
just not getting an easy pushover yeah
yeah right and then i
just remember being very mad like during
those years like where i just was mad
all the time like i just was like [ __ ]
man like
you can't catch a break like [ __ ] me
alone yeah like [ __ ] me i gotta be like
the stoke like i felt like i got to be
like stoic or something like because i
wanted to be like a jokey jokey guy you
know but
as soon as i would crack jokes people
take it too far and i have to like
try to fight people and i was like what
the [ __ ] is this about yeah that sucks
but i think that's that's just the age
right that's the age range where
you're trying to figure out what you're
about or who are you who you're supposed
to be
right yeah well people would just at
that i think specifically at that age
a lot of young people are trying to
establish
their dominance by pushing somebody else
down yeah yeah and so they would be
known as a strong person a cool guy if
they could bully somebody because they
look like the alpha male it's just as
barbaric and caveman as it gets oh yeah
you know and also you're dealing with a
lot of insecurity at that time yeah
like girls and then you feel like you
know you're just you don't even know who
you are you feel like kind of
intimidated by other people yeah let me
just punk this dude and feel like
somewhat good about myself you know so
there's that going on too
it's just a weird weird [ __ ] age but
the right thing you have to stand up
that's the only thing that's really the
only option
you gotta give a little resistance at
least a little bit you got to make it
you got to make the other person's life
a little harder if they're trying to
[ __ ] with you right
and even if you get your ass kicked at
the end of the day it's like okay well i
if i [ __ ] with this dude i might i'll i
might win but it's going to be a fight
you know it's going to be because
his name was uh his name was [ __ ]
gerardo big ass [ __ ]
this [ __ ] full head like alex's head
but
he's like my height so this guy was huge
he was a relatively nice dude but i
don't know what got into him where out
of nowhere we were like homies and then
he tried
to make me the butt of the joke every
time yeah but i don't know
i guess he got a high off of that [ __ ]
or some [ __ ] but another weird thing
like he's a big guy i remember we didn't
fight
but i should run in my mind thinking
this guy's gonna kill me
but i just couldn't let him keep doing
it yeah yeah and so i
we just got to that point where we were
in in the middle of the quad
at uh james rutter middle school and i
was like you know what
after school let's just [ __ ] go i'm
gonna beat your [ __ ] ass and you know
i'm a geeky dude thick-ass glasses or
whatever but i'm a big guy i'm like
we're going to [ __ ]
we're going to do this [ __ ] right and he
meets me after school and i just
remember in my mind thinking like this
guy's going to
[ __ ] me up because he was one of those
kids that are just buffed for no [ __ ]
reason
yeah he didn't really wait train or
anything else he's just like really big
[ __ ]
genetics he's came up to me and he was
like hey man i'm sorry i hurt your
feelings and i was like thank god
this guy would have killed me what a
nice guy though yeah
how old were you guys we were uh what 12
13. for him to apologize to you because
most
boys won't do that [ __ ] they're like
[ __ ] you so [ __ ] because i couldn't tell
i was like i was kind of i was more
hurt because you're supposed to be my
friend i was like [ __ ] this we're going
to throw daddy just like hey man i'm
sorry man i apologize and i just
wave of relief i was like he would have
murdered me he would have had his way
with me
he was so strong though yeah but he's
just a really sweet dude but i don't
know why he did that but i think it was
just him being young
and contesting trying that energy right
but we were friends so it was like
i don't think he really considered the
fact that he was hurting my feelings
and he thought maybe i was in on the day
he realized and then he apologized
let's give a round of applause for her
although yeah thank you so much that's
how you operate your life
that's how you do it that is nice do you
have any more questions
that's the main one today actually
there's probably more but they're so
[ __ ] long people have like real
problems here and i don't want to [ __ ]
up your guys's life dude
let's see another advice let's do
another one let's do another one let's
see what's up let's see what's popping
like come on
stop sending dick size questions man no
let's answer it
yeah how many dick size questions are
you getting a lot that like hey man my
dick's like 12 inches is that too small
like maybe i'm like yeah that's tiny
dude
ah tight here we go dude we're gonna
leave this one anonymous
all right go perfect
uh they're hoping that edrick is not on
this podcast but he's not i'm sorry but
we have
two uh great guests here anyways so i
dated someone for about four and a half
years before we broke up
i really felt like we loved each other
and had plans for marriage but he had
suddenly broken up with me saying he'd
rather focus on his career
than settle down we kept in contact on
and off after the breakup after a year
later ooh that's always a bad sign man
uh we have start we started seeing each
other again however
there are some twists to the story oh
girl you getting saucy yeah baby
first the last year or two of our
relationship he stopped having sex with
me
what always a red flag right either he's
masturbating frequently or he's cheating
on you
he would always say he was tired and not
in the mood uh
just as a preface we were long distance
oh
uh but even during the times we traveled
together or visit each other he would
still not be interested in sex
he would never approach me first and i
always had to make the first move damn i
would i
wish for me for for me
i could feel he didn't want it so my
body naturally started rejecting it
whenever we tried to have sex he
literally couldn't get it in
um sex was painful basically impossible
uh plus i started to find a porn on his
computer couldn't get it in
he's like that's what he was soft uh it
really ruined my self-esteem
always he would rather he would rather
watch porn intimate with me
i confronted him about it and he just
treated like it was no big deal it
really felt shitty going to bed next to
him it felt like he wasn't attracted to
me anymore
he would always fall asleep before i
even came to bed he made
little to no efforts to be intimate with
me afterwards i felt rejected and so
upset
damn girl swerved this fall in a
heartbeat yeah
now i mentioned that we have started
seeing each other again although we had
been in contact he made it clear that he
didn't want to get back into a
relationship with me
but he would always help me since i'm
living abroad as a grad student in his
home country right now i started
developing feelings for him again
then one day he decided to give me his
ipad to use for studying
and you best know i snooped he had
he had told me he's very smart yeah he's
not very smart at all he didn't see
anyone after we broke up but
his ipad said otherwise of course
actually he started seeing another girl
in the last few months of our
relationship he cheated
i felt like oh of course he did right i
felt like
absolute [ __ ] after finding this out and
seeing all the photos
why have photo evidence bro and honestly
what is it
okay yo yo
if you're cheating don't have don't
collect your own evidence bro
i'm sure that's been said before right i
mean yeah yeah yeah i'd be cracking up
if the photos were
of them at a park i'm like you brought
your ipad to take photos yeah
you [ __ ] deep my grandma does that
apologies to your grandma
he also admitted to have slept with
other women after the breakup after many
days of thinking i decided to give him a
chance girl you gotta [ __ ] yo what are
you doing
bro get rid of this guy i haven't
forgotten i haven't forgiven him for the
cheating and lying
and we are not officially back together
but i'm willing to see how he behaves as
a as if he has changed no he's not going
to change
trust uh this [ __ ] again i know
we have a lot of issues to figure out
understatement
but one that still bothers me did she
write that or did you say yeah
even now i feel he is not attracted to
me sexually he will he will give me
smooches and call me cute
but listen unless he's eating that [ __ ]
he's not unless he's eating that box
yeah that box dude that amazon
box that bird baby blindfolded all up in
the muff
but he didn't seem to see me bird scenes
but he doesn't seem to see me as a woman
i'm worried things will repeat
themselves uh i can i can't make him
feel attracted to me but sex is such an
important part of a relationship
100 is i don't want to feel like how i
did before
why was he able to have sex with so many
other women but not me
uh why would probably your head game is
bad just kidding uh why would he prefer
to watch porn that have sex with me
is it normal for men to consistently
watch porn while in a relationship
i could truly feel that he loved me and
cared for me but why does it feel like
he is not attracted to me i am confused
and would like to hear your advice
thank you how do we break all this down
young lady number one
um i could break this down in so many
different ways and let's talk about the
sex
well when you're going through right now
and the reason why i could talk about
this is because
i know people who have been in similar
maybe not as severe situations as you
but right now you think the problem is
him the problem is actually you
you're the problem not in the
relationship per se they're up on the
count you
you have you have an issue of value of
yourself
you actually don't value yourself enough
yeah you remind me of myself when i was
17 when i was with somebody thinking
that my value was linked to the person
that i was with rather than myself
that's your biggest issue right now
you're waiting for somebody to change
when they have no want to change yeah
what the [ __ ] are you waiting for
yeah right what are you waiting for i
don't understand yeah i think it's
important to ask yourself like why am i
tolerating this
because obviously this isn't how she
knows that this isn't how a relationship
should be so you should ask yourself
like
what is it why what are my insecurities
or what am i lacking
that i think that this is okay for this
to be potentially somebody that i'm with
again like
he cheated he's sexually not there like
there's so many red flags you're not
happy
look if your butt naked and his dick is
soft there should be a moment where you
guys are having conversations with each
other
clearly you seem like a young person or
if you're older and you're not having
sit-down conversations with the person
that you're with that's going to be a
big issue red flag so what you're trying
to do right now
what i feel anyways from the information
that you're giving me is that
you're not really tackling things
head-on which i don't even think you
should have to tackle this stuff head-on
because it seems like it's already been
dealt with
you just you're waiting for somebody
change but if you if you do want to
change you guys can't sit down and have
a conversation how are you ever going to
progress yeah if you can't say to him
hey
when i'm trying to [ __ ] you when your
dick is soft what the [ __ ] is going on
and he just goes oh it's not a big deal
you're not in a relationship with the
person at all that person is in a
relationship with himself
right and also just cut this one's done
yeah this relationship's over
been over for a long time it sounds like
your losses stop wasting your time
he might he might be like a very nice
guy but he's treating you like [ __ ]
at the end of it right because when
you're in a relationship you're trying
to take care of the person
it's a it's a mutual understanding but
it sounds like he's not trying to
[ __ ]
come around because when you ask the
question too is
god are you know guys watching porn
normal i mean what's normal i guess if
you guys know about it
yeah you know if you know that he
doesn't know that he does then i guess
it's very relative like what's
considered normal
but also like with the sex thing right
it's like the one thing that guys could
really get on board with
in a relationship is probably sex across
the board right right and if this if
you're like kind of throwing yourself at
this dude and he's just like
nope not today it's either he's gay
or he's [ __ ] somebody else or he's a
[ __ ] ass turns out he was [ __ ]
somebody else right
exactly so multiple people right and
what you're doing right now you're
saying
is when he cheats on you and he has he
has sexual interactions with somebody
else you go
what's wrong with me yeah there's
nothing wrong with you exactly you guys
aren't on the same page he's uh
clearly a scumbag if he's doing that
behind your back and still willing to
keep you around knowing that he has no
interest in you yeah that's [ __ ]
weird that's a weird thing because if
it's like if you're if he's not
interested
why stay around yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy
there's no there's nothing to gain out
of this situation it's a lose-lose
achievement here's the thing too
young lady you have all the power right
yeah you for real
leave yeah you can like it's easier said
than done because sometimes i feel like
when you're in these like committed
loving relationships where you want to
love somebody so bad
it's hard for you to step out of it
because you're scared of what you're
going to lose
yeah right and not much you're ain't
going to lose much you're not enough
much you could always find somebody
that'll find you attractive
even if it's not this person he's not
even trying to do the bare minimum
yeah bro he's like hey i'm not cheating
on you but here's the proof
yeah check it out on the ipad
on my desktop when i was [ __ ] here
he's got his laptop his wallpaper is
just a girl with a gum shot on her face
he's like what's the problem babe yeah
it's porn you know i watch
porn yeah what's what's good about this
though
is after if just break up with this dude
like you literally can only go up
yeah for real unless the next guy you
date just beats you
like you're literally on top of doing
all this obviously don't date
anybody that beats you that's science
yeah that's you can literally
like literally go you can only go up you
know what i mean that's good advice
yeah but that's true though i feel like
this is one of the
i thought when you said the first thing
about how like he doesn't have sex with
you i thought that was gonna be it yeah
and then you kept unloading the rest of
the stuff and i was like oh bro you have
to
delete this guy from your life yeah
she's uh she's [ __ ] victim blaming
right now because she's sitting here
saying well
why can't he have other sex with women
and not me that's not the question you
should be asking
that's not the issue yeah he's kind of a
dirt bag yeah he's kind of a dirt bag
i don't even care if you if you hate
somebody i feel like if you hated some
girl that you dated
you would never do that to her 100 you
would never do that like you wouldn't go
out of your way just to like
string her along you are in a very look
at this sentence this is so sad because
i could truly feel that he loved me and
cared for me but why does it feel like
he is not attracted to me
that's a very very sad sentence people
are really good at uh
some people could be really good at
faking that not faking it but like you
know making it seem that like oh i love
you and being affectionate yeah he wants
to have his cake and eat it too and
you're willing to take the abuse because
you feel like you love him and he
should love you but he did not yeah
right because that that ain't true love
no yeah like cause like i like i've been
cheated on a couple times right and like
it doesn't feel [ __ ] great it's just
kind of like
you get blindsided and you're like what
the [ __ ] and the first thing that you do
is tend to say like
what did i do yeah like did i do
something which sometimes i you know if
you're in a loving relationship and a
long-term relationship and cheating
happens there
is from what i found from my personal
experiences with other other friends who
have dealt with
it there is a little personal blame
right so for example with um
i i had a buddy who got cheated on and
for him he had to deal with it by
at first he was like upset and enraged
but because i knew this couple
it's not that i could justify the
cheating right but i understood
the void that she felt because i know
how the relationship happened
right so it's like when when there was a
uh
like a coming to jesus moment they were
opening up i understood why
why why she felt the way that she felt
she felt very unheard
she felt that he would talk down to her
like she was dumb and
you know she found that in somebody else
and it was a big mistake and she
couldn't
she was like trapped in this world of i
still love this man um
because he has such great qualities like
he's faithful as [ __ ]
but he just doesn't make me feel like
i'm a woman and i feel very special so
there is that give and take for sure
you know so i you know we could we can
do that scenario where
we look at the cheating situation and
both people can take responsibility for
why
exactly right yeah and usually when that
happens and both people can understand
it they usually
from what i've seen anyways like this is
like two three couples they've been able
to work out of it
where they go oh [ __ ] my bad i [ __ ] up
you know i've i've definitely been
pushing you aside even though i've been
cheating on you
you have been like the least priority in
my life right and because of that you
felt
this need to push you away yeah yeah
yeah so it doesn't really excuse the
cheating that he or she did
not but i took it another level this
guy's a little weird you know yeah
yeah this guy is like he has like a
weird control because right now for what
i'm what i don't know like
what i'm inferring from when you're
asking about the porn thing maybe you're
kind of alluding that he might have a
porn addiction which is why he can't get
hard
which is the case because i know
somebody who actually has a porn
addiction and he could not get hard
because he was masturbating so
[ __ ] much wow and so his his version
of [ __ ] that would turn him on
it was like it was skewed now it would
be like porno [ __ ]
so when he would try to [ __ ] if it
wasn't porno [ __ ] it's like it wasn't
for you
it wasn't it wasn't real sex so he
couldn't get a [ __ ] erection
so i don't think that's the case because
he's [ __ ] another woman yeah so yeah
he did fine
he dig working good hit dick working
really good really cool
a little too good this guy's actually
killing it yeah
but also it's like smorgasburg like if
if he wasn't necessarily like interested
in somebody
like i i just can't wrap my head around
why this guy
is like probably because she's like how
much you want to bet she does every
anything and everything for this
and it's just there's comfort things too
yeah that's true you know here's some
real advice do you want to be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] for the rest of your life
like you want to be this dude's [ __ ]
that's the davidson stamp of approval
yeah that's right that's how you make it
so advice yeah this is
so i've done the nice thing about this
is my real advice yeah you're trying to
be
but you need both though you need a
little bit of the fire because you need
a fire under your butt for you to be
like you know what [ __ ] this fool
yeah yeah because clearly he's a [ __ ]
he's taking advantage of you
like what are you worth are you is this
is it you're worth more than that girl
okay
let me tell you something baby tell you
yeah let me tell you something you don't
need this dude
i'll tell you something when you wake up
that [ __ ] shining baby yeah you got
some power you got the power you'd be
quiffing out some glitter if you could
baby
you gotta find some [ __ ] this is a
wendy williams [ __ ] right yeah yeah
absolutely though [ __ ] this oh yeah some
real [ __ ] though like do you value
yourself that [ __ ] little where you
could be dragged through the [ __ ]
trash like that and then you still say
what's wrong with me yeah have some
[ __ ] self-esteem like [ __ ] believe
in yourself a little bit
what are you waiting around for like
nobody here will probably tell you this
in your circle they'll probably tell me
he's a bad guy he's a bad guy that's
already a given you have something
that's in your control right now you
have
an ability to leave you can leave yeah
and you should have a long time ago yeah
and let me tell you something if you
want to message me again after you hear
this i'll tell you a way to [ __ ] with
his head
where he's going to feel [ __ ] up for
the rest of he's really good at that
yeah if you guys didn't know about the
chipotle
story about how the guy came here
yeah my accent's on point i didn't know
[ __ ]
was crying yeah it is i like that yeah
that's where it actually originated
actually i can't even do a [ __ ] uh a
french try go now you want some
oh boom i took french one
belfay didn't do that well that was good
clearly
la douche is shower that's only fine
girls don't you guys don't even
understand like how much power women
have over men
you have no idea like you need to
utilize it
some people do more than others but this
girl right here
you know why he [ __ ] with you so much
is because he knows that no matter what
he does to you
you will [ __ ] stay yeah and if he's
an abusive
[ __ ] yeah like if you leave he's going
to start crying and it's going to make
you probably want to get back with him
but don't
buy it because watch watch if you did
i'm not telling you it's like number one
[ __ ]
yeah i'm not telling you you should play
games with the people that you with that
you're with and you care about but he
doesn't care about you so now it's time
to play [ __ ] games
because imagine if he thinks that you
know he has all this power over you and
then when he's coming over to give you
smooches and you're like the [ __ ] are
you doing
yeah could you imagine like hold on a
second i own this girl
why is she saying no smooches yeah yeah
right and then he might try to play it
off a little bit
but you go off you have like a couple of
pictures with some random dudes that
you're having the time of your life and
you go hey ma'am i'll go hang out with
my buddies have a great time
don't even do [ __ ] salty yeah don't give
people that strength
do it in a way oh i'm [ __ ] okay do it
don't do it
do it in a way you know what i'm saying
you gotta make sure you got a [ __ ]
coming out that coochie yeah
baby preach because imagine too if he's
coming in and you guys are about to i
don't know let's say have a date you're
about to cuddle and stuff
and then you go oh [ __ ] i forgot i'm
gonna hang out with my friends today are
you cool
he's like and he starts throwing a
[ __ ] fit you're like all right and
you just walk out and do your own thing
yeah and then later on you have a talk
with him and you go like hey i don't
think this is working out not angry
though
not sad yeah but just matter of fact
it's like yeah it's actually not that
dope i don't know what i'm doing
all right you just walk out like you
broke your friends is broke yeah
you are [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't like you
yeah
your tooth crazy stanky yeah yeah yeah
you got a dead tooth man
i don't want to make myself sweet yeah
i'm making millions please right back if
he has a dead tooth that'd be making me
very
hilarious yo tooth is dead like this for
life [ __ ]
but also [ __ ] that dude and like what
david said you just you break up with
this dude
indifferent and that's how you do it you
should be indifferent at this point yeah
because this dude
he's being indifferent towards you and
like he's very disrespectful this guy
this guy i don't like this guy let me
give you a great example
let me give you a number one best
example i had this one girl that i was
with
that i think that i was i was very
obsessed with and
she knew that i was obsessed with her
right and she wasn't she was never a bad
person but she had this habit of trying
to be with people that she could fix
so in the relationship she was always
top dog right and for her
if the guy that she was wasn't giving
her the right attention or
it just wasn't working she would kind of
start talking to somebody else right so
we we broke up and then i was still like
you were still trying to chase after
this person for some [ __ ] reason
because they had like this
this this leash on me i decided to
you know gain some balls like what the
[ __ ] am i doing
lo and behold we ended up still being
friends you know i was very flirtatious
with her but i didn't
i wasn't emotionally invested into her
anymore so
what happened was one day she came over
and she was like
so i broke up with um the guy that i'm
with and there was like an awkward
silence
and in my mind i'm like oh did you come
over here to tell me
that oh i choose you now yeah you know
and i remember i looked at her
and this was a really good power moment
for me i looked and i was like so what
are you doing here and it was like this
awkward silence that's that was the
actual noise she made
she was nate robinson on the floor and
all the vietnamese [ __ ] spirits
looking at her
it was nam fans staring at her
she was just like i remember she sit
there and i just kind of laughed at her
i was like
what are you doing here right she goes
oh i'm just you know kind of telling you
like things are over awesome wow i was
like well you're gonna get with some
random dude
after this fight right you're here again
with some broke-ass losers and i
remember she was like upset she goes no
i'm gonna be single i was like
you're never single you're like you're
always trying to fix somebody so i
guarantee you within a couple months
you're gonna find some loser and you're
gonna be with him
right yeah and i could just see the rage
in her eyes like oh you're so wrong you
don't know me right
lo and behold she gets together with
somebody a couple weeks later
and it was somebody that she was working
with so clearly she was talking with
that guy as she
the other relationship was falling apart
yeah because when i was with her she did
the same thing to me yeah so i know her
especially because
she and i were really good friends
before we got together so i know her
habits
so you know that was a power trip mom
was like oh
the [ __ ] tables have turned this is
my [ __ ] now you came here because
you thought that i was waiting on your
beck and call because i flirt i still
flirted with her i thought she was super
cute
but i wasn't emotionally invested into
it yeah yeah right so when she came in
with the whole thing of while i'm single
now i'm like okay
story right get the [ __ ] out then later
and i was like excuse me you think you
owned
and she was like david why are you
talking like that and she starts taking
her clothes off because she's super
attractive
you better put your clothes back on baby
because unless that [ __ ] gonna be a
[ __ ] dinner blanket i don't need that
[ __ ]
unless it's gonna be draped over the
table baby put it back on them tiny
titties
damn did you that must have actually
really happened because there's no way
you would have come up with that on the
spot oh no i'm a good improver dude
no no that's exactly what you said i did
not say that she was still my friend
come on here guys that happened word for
word you guys that was good
wow yeah i hated her i think we're good
at advice man
i think we're i think we knocked that
one out the party dudes that beat you
yeah let's start with that right
you see that have porn on his ipad and
then hand it to you but also
porn that he's in like [ __ ] naked
pictures
like do you have to realize how little
he thinks of you to the point where he
had the i think
with all the evidence he goes watch this
[ __ ] and i
bet you you still won't [ __ ] leave
wow and i bet he probably jokes with his
buddies
all the time generate buddies that are
like oh go check out what i'm doing this
to this person you know it's like i'm
not not a cool guy
this guy i think he's uh because this is
a form of abuse
it is abuse this is straight abuse and
you you're taking it because
you know he's kind of what are you
what's that stockholm syndrome i don't
know like
you're a prisoner well she's like yeah
she's just insecure there's something
lacking where she like doesn't value
herself [ __ ] that [ __ ] you gotta break
up like
he's praying on that break up with his
dude he's trash
his dick ain't trash trash he can't even
get hard
trash trash his dick ain't even big girl
that [ __ ] three
inches you know what three inches also
his personality cause that boy got
nothing going for him he broke
he ugly no money nobody love him
good luck to the next girl cause i bet
you when he ends up with her she gonna
find out how small her dick is at least
oh okay and you take that to the [ __ ]
bank
that's the [ __ ] bank that's
right you [ __ ] catch that [ __ ] dude
yeah that guy sucks that guy number one
[ __ ]
in the comments below talk about what a
[ __ ] bag that guy is yeah yeah but
yeah yeah he's a [ __ ] bag
but right now on some real advice you're
being a little [ __ ] bag yourself
because you're allowing this [ __ ] to
happen that's true remember that's true
you you're better than this [ __ ] yeah
and also you need friends around you
that tell you things like this
yeah what are your [ __ ] friends yeah
we're your friends we're your friends
now and guess what i'm gonna say
something very profound
and probably something that no one has
ever said but you were the master of
your own destiny
wow that was great dude give me that
self-help come on baby what's your
self-help book called
um what is it in the nick of time
come on baby let's go that was good
let's go i didn't think you're gonna
land it but you mean either that was
nice
wow that was i kept thinking about joel
olsen in my head i don't know why
that was i don't know why he jailed me
yeah that's like the russian the russian
uh olympian that has a sprained ankle
that you wouldn't think was going to
land it yeah pistorius
and she stuck she was like slovenian
pistorius is the guy that had
no legs and killed his girlfriend that's
pistorius do you guys remember that guy
who's that guy you just love death
he's the guy he's the south bro this is
like a huge story this is a huge story
what is the story
he had no legs he was in like he was
like one of the most famous like
paralympic
sprinters and i'm sorry wait what was
going on here
how's he spreading without legs he has
the the the
the bendy things the bending moments the
prosthetic
broke into his house but it was his
girlfriend oh i did i do he started
shooting through the wall and he killed
her
and he was like oh but i thought it was
an intruder yeah but it was like
i know he was trying to get rid of his
girlfriend and he like too many times
something like that it was like where it
was like uh what
he walked up blah blah blah blah blah
blah and it was like oh i thought it was
underneath
yeah yeah it was crazy he should have
had prosthetic arms that would have
never happened
they should have taken away his arms
instead of his legs before still would
have shot him with his toes with a
shotgun like this
i thought it was an intruder yeah you
shot her with a shotgun with your feet
there's plenty of time to figure that
out
but this guy he had a rig so he murdered
her on purpose i think he did i'm pretty
sure it's like
everything was pointing to i remember i
don't know if you gotta quitted though
but i don't know if he did either but
they were pointing towards like
it was very obvious it was his
girlfriend
how did you do this yeah this was
clearly a murder
i don't have legs
if i don't have legs in jail what's
going to happen to me
he's like bending over a little bit i
know don't you know if you're starving
for me
oh i would get out of jail super fast
yeah this guy's good damn sending davis
out of jail
that's your new tv show relax man
how long does david snow survive in jail
i don't think i would either i wouldn't
either i would do the first thing that
people tell you to do when you go in
jail is to make a statement and beat up
the strongest guy oh
[ __ ] but i would get stabbed to death
immediately yeah i feel like they don't
play that [ __ ] you want my waffles
yeah you ain't getting my waffles like
why is he talking like that you don't
have to kill me to get my waffles
they're like we're not even eating
waffles they're pancakes
there's somebody in the back they're
pancakes they're clearly pancakes
they're clearly pancakes yeah don't come
in my yard hear my wife house
he's walking around the [ __ ]
cafeteria doing holding pancakes these
my waffles
got crazy dude yeah yeah i think we do
well in prison actually yeah
redact that hey catch uh nick's new book
in the nick of time
come on make it time i'm actually very
surprised usually you crumble at those
situations i don't know
i usually i usually drop the ball i'm
gonna do another one i'm at the 20 oh
do another you're asking for lightning
to hit in the same place twice and i
don't think i can promise that for you
wow i'm actually really proud of you
right now me too i'm happy thanks man
like you made me happy some people
some people ask me hey do you have a
concussion right now that's what they
usually say
yeah because i'm usually like slurring
my words because you made that face like
it wasn't going to happen you made that
and we're like no yeah my face was very
like it's stoic
what's my self-help book called
so what that's what it's called so
that's actually pretty good
that's pretty good yeah exactly that's
exactly how i always give advice
i was beat as a chopstick so what
that's it and that's how you live your
life i cover the book is him crying on a
bike in the thunderstorm
electrocuted hit by thunder
all right that's all my dad in the back
all right
my dad used to love yelling that was his
hobby actually he would just wake us up
in the morning like that my uncle used
to do that [ __ ] too really
he actually got in trouble from uh my
aunt because wake us up
hey wake up lazy jackasses she's like
can you stop saying that to the kids
that's pretty mild though i was
expecting something like way worse but
who says that to children when they're
sleeping
on a saturday that's true like it's a
saturday
he's like wake up lazy jackasses and she
goes
why do you always do that at 7 00 am
yeah leave them alone they're kids
like come on dude i'm jacking off here
guys was it a military guy
uh he well long story short with him
we can go on a tirade about this guy but
he was like a like an
og in sacramento in in this area called
elk grove was like a like a
cowboy like horse town or some [ __ ] at
the time but he was like the only asian
dude in that area
i think that was in the golden state
documentary so he was like the only
asian dude in the area but
he was one of those guys that you just
couldn't punk so back in the day and
even until now
because of some old-timey lob like
nunchucks are considered like a deadly
weapon if you get caught with nunchucks
like getting caught with a gun
so he was notorious and known for
[ __ ] people up with nunchucks in that
area
that's so dope so it is really like
there's a storyline bruce lee yeah
there's a story that um so his uh his
son my cousin
told me when he was working at a bank he
met this other guy like an older dude i
think he either worked at the bank i
don't know what the story is but
he looked at him he goes hey you kind of
look like uh this guy named song
right he goes oh yeah that's my dad he
goes sure dad
i was like what's he doing now what's he
up to he was like oh he's a he
teaches at folsom prison like he's like
a correctional office type of thing he
goes
you mean he's in jail he goes no no no
he teaches at the jail he goes
your father teaches right because he
just remembered him
[ __ ] people up back in the day like
literally going to parties
he teach that's what he teaches at the
prison how to stay alive
so he would make your own nunchucks one
of the stories
there's a lot of stories about him but
he told the story of when um
you know he was an asian dude so people
a lot of people try to say racist [ __ ]
to him so he
wanted to be somebody who couldn't get
punk so he joined the football team
so he was like the only asian dude in
the football team and he would go to
these parties
or some somebody would say some racist
[ __ ] and he said this one time this dude
at a house parties did like a [ __ ] joke
in him
took his nunchucks and [ __ ] wrecked
this dude's car smashed every
[ __ ] window with the nunchucks dude
that makes me very happy inside
yeah and he had to because he was the
only asian dude in that whole [ __ ]
area right so he had to make sure that
nobody was going to [ __ ] his statement
that's how you make a statement
which makes sense because he would beat
my ass all the time and he has old man
strength
so he would always [ __ ] me up because i
was like such a clown and so he just
hated all the jokes that i would make
this will just pin me down and beat me
up dude david has such an interesting
story that's wild dude i always think
you're going to run out of stories but
you would never do it
like it's like everybody's story around
me because they they're
i just remember things very well so your
uncle's bruce lee that he's like a comic
book character dude just beating the
show everybody he's shane
bro he's the guy he's how [ __ ] nuts
is it that uh
somebody like my cousin's person that he
met at work knows his dad
yeah because of how much of a badass he
is yeah and my buddy ed park the other
one he has a similar story with his dad
he did he found out that his dad was in
a korean gang because his youth pastor
at the time remembered his dad
he was an original founding member of
this group called uh kk which known as
korean killers
and they were a gang that's in one more
k though
so you want to know a funny story about
that his mom
his mom would tell them stories when he
was younger would always tell him not to
be in gangs because of his dad
and so she goes don't join gangs don't
be in kkk
the korean guy because mom i can't be in
the kkk
there's no way i would get it he never
knew what that was from until he met
that youth pastor and he goes crazy he
goes no it's kk for korean killers and
he goes
now i know what my mom was saying this
whole time i thought the ku klux klan
yeah oh yeah man wow crazy stories dude
that's [ __ ] wild that's [ __ ] nice
yeah there's
some there's a lot more stories about
him but i can't remember right now i
have to ask him but he that's that's
what he was known for
should you get him on the podcast no
he's a little nuts he's he's [ __ ]
crazy he's
a [ __ ] good podcast that would be
that would be great but i would have to
deal with him the whole time because he
kind of irritates me he's like one of
those guys that makes jokes and he waits
until you laugh at it
so he'll do a joke like this right hey
this is his voice by the way
hey so um trump's kind of
crazy huh huh
huh yeah yeah yeah
yeah right yeah yeah so he's like a real
old guy yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah man he's
crazy
he's crazy i know you were actually i
knew that was david but that made me
uncomfortable
yeah so that's every [ __ ]
thanksgiving for me wow and he likes to
always pray so you saw him on
thanksgiving
no i did not i avoided him like corona
was he there so no he was not we had we
had to do separate thanksgivings because
of roanoke see that's
that's the other beauty of corona
sometimes like you know you don't get to
see certain family members that you
don't really want to see
that's true [ __ ] this fool's
thanksgiving prayers 30 minutes long
oh dear god i like to thank you for the
dew drops on the blades of grass that
you have provided for us
lord because without the dewdrops there
would be no moisture without moisture
there is no water
plants what are plants like like oh [ __ ]
uncle shut the [ __ ] up i knew there's
one lady that we used to
like i used to coach
and she's infamous for being one of
those people that just like once they
start talking to you
okay they're talking at you they're not
literally so they'll be like
oh so the other day i was looking
through the newspaper and i was i was
wondering why there was firefighters
going down the street and my son used to
be a firefighter
and he's about 28 years old and the
thing about him is that paramedics right
that and she would go on and everybody
would as soon as she would come by
everybody would just slowly scout so
that's my uncle but just add
random like lightweight racist [ __ ] in
there hilarious
yeah that's cool there you go this will
walk up to one of one of one of my uh
cousin's friends we were chilling no
paprika and i remember this because i
was so mortified he looks at him
and his friend's puerto rican he goes
hey what are you
he goes puerto rican he goes a lot of
you in prison
nice dude hell yeah bro
[ __ ] yeah i was not expecting that way
to put your best foot forward
a lot of you in prison okay he just goes
right upstairs
like hey why'd you do that dude
we just eat cereal in the living room
why did i do that you know what's funny
is like human beings are constantly
looking for patterns and that was the
pattern he
made with that person yeah you know it's
like because you know some people like
the other version of that is oh like my
one of my my sister's best friend is
puerto rican oh cool
you know but then his mind was oh
there's a lot of humor
then he walked away thinking i just made
a connection with that yeah
he wrote it he wrote in his diary that
was really cool
i told the puerto rican guy that a lot
of his relatives didn't prison
amen in his [ __ ] journal
amen praise the lord well guys that
wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast
i hope you guys enjoyed that episode uh
love you guys uh
my family's nuts uh if you guys haven't
noticed
you can find patrick at patrick.t.riley
at instagram and everything else and
then you have nick the ear at
nick the
that's the west side huh yeah we're
throwing it up we're throwing out my
baby just in the nick of time
your boy is gonna pee his pants damn see
y'all next time
peace